[Music]
well hello there
and thanks for joining us today on the
HD broadcast live today's episode is
sponsored by candid should I keep up
with it now you know because Dan even
getting a note from Dan today's video is
sponsored by candid four hams quip and
23andme now today we have with us bill
words musician video producer youtuber
what else are I mean artists most
certainly how else is there any
classification I missed no person person
let's not forget that species species
yes animal yeah how are you dude great
great great having you oh geez thank you
so thank you for having me thanks for
crank here how was the house it here in
LA it's it rained yeah it is typical I
suppose I think it's kind of funny
because it never ever rains in LA and
your logo is the umbrella yeah here you
come to Los Angeles you brought and we
brought the ring with you which in LA is
a miracle I would say yeah so you are a
miraculous young man
well that's very that's very nice of you
happens Oh tell me about I want to know
about okay well that your first hit your
first big hit okay yeah was that depends
how you wear your where you're looking
well in your timeline of working what
were your first you're more like know
what's going on bill words well it's all
relative but here's the thing it was
like nobody nobody nothing until the
gonna mail you my floor got about 200
likes very quickly on vine which 200
compared to 0 is like what's happening
right yeah so but after that it was um
school on fine I don't want to go to
school it was shaving my piano and then
it was bench and then I don't know do
you know how people first found yes you
on vine well yeah yeah I can tell you
the first the first person
the first person who did it was a guy
named Jack duros dart player his he had
a vine called back back pain or pain
back or something like that but yeah he
was he was a big fan and he just sort of
he just sort of you know gave me a thing
you know to read the thing that's
amazing that he just found you in the
nether no well he found me on Twitter so
yeah yeah no but that was good that was
good and then and then more people did
it yeah and it was all from that first
200 likes kind of like a steady client
yeah I was kind of like yeah I I'd like
to think that it was inevitable because
your style is so unique and everything
about like your editing and your music
you have such a refined specific style
so unique to you I think it was
inevitable destiny in the put model I
was metal that's I mean that's that was
the strategy I was doing it for a long
long time just like I don't care how
long were you doing it before anybody
noticed well I started the five day
schedule in early 2014 which was
basically where I just snapped because
before that it was like I wanted to do a
million things and thought I could do
anything but didn't know how to put it
together but mmm finally somewhere along
the line I just snapped and I just said
okay we're doing five days a week video
every day you said I'm just gonna grind
I don't know what I don't know how to
figure out how to put all this stuff in
my mind right so I'm just gonna force
myself to work work work work work yeah
and unfortunately they have to be very
short if you do one every single day so
why did you decide to think what did you
think the vine was the right medium well
that wasn't until I didn't even know
about fine yet I was doing it on the
website actually just the website for
the first month alerts calm yeah and
then someone told me a friend said oh
you're making videos why don't you put
them on YouTube and I said I like I like
it when it's when you get the file
and you can just watch the file like I
don't really like streaming actually cuz
I like to be able to pause it and horse
it around and really see what you're
dealing with so so yeah I didn't really
like YouTube but but he was like what
you know you got to be on YouTube so
okay so I did you do good so which is
pretty cool but
I don't know it's yeah but you had your
your break on mine
that was probably yeah it was where
things started and you put your posting
simultaneously to YouTube invited yes
the trick was I'd already gone down to
two week on YouTube and then I
discovered vine and I was like that
would be would be great because it you
can't go longer so no one could be mad
you know so and they loop so the best
way to watch short videos anyways to see
him over and over again I figured so I
put them there I started putting them
all there in order and I had to do a
little bit of editing to square if I
them and in some cases edit them down to
to the six from in some cases 20 seconds
down to 16 it was kind of fun but yeah I
put him there and I wasn't even gonna
touch him and then and I was doing
Twitter too so I had decent following on
Twitter oh yeah someone found me like I
said it was it was someone found me
there and then and then yeah and so do
you think that that as so for this
amount of time you're grinding on vine
doing a video 5 times a week do you feel
like that was like a really important
creative yeah I'm in your life yeah well
unfortunately I was desperate to stop as
soon as as soon as it got going on vine
because I already had like at that point
I was doing two a week on YouTube and
then as soon as I discovered the vine
started to do its thing I was like okay
well I got all these on hand cuz I
wasn't done uploading them all so then I
said okay I'm just gonna well hold on
you had a backlog yes because I had
because it was like a year after year
and a half after I'd started doing them
five days a week
mmm thought I started on vine so you
were grunt yeah so so you were grinding
and grinding in private and you had this
incredible backlog of content they
wasn't private it was on YouTube okay
and it was on the website okay but I
hadn't reached a month audience yes so
you were like man I've got like a whole
library right of content yeah and you
were getting followers before you even
were forced to make new stuff on vine
but you were editing it down right so I
was yeah so I figured I had these on
hand so I would edit them and release
him on a day so it was easy enough cuz I
was doing two new ones and seven days a
week I just figured since I have them
I'll do 7 p.m. every single that's so
and then I was like okay according to my
calculations in two months
Ananta and i'm gonna have to make a
decision I'm gonna have to either put
the vine thing down to two a week mm-hmm
or accelerate everything to seven a week
which was even more than I was doing
before and this was after I was so sick
of doing short videos I could just cry
and I was already thinking about doing
much much bigger things I was thinking
about history at that point mm-hmm
but but now I'm stuck doing seven seven
short videos a week and how important
was it for you to have a schedule and to
really stick to it oh it's it's life or
death really because because if you
don't you'll drown because you can do
it's infinite you could spend infinite
time doing something so wait you're
saying the schedule helps you escape the
work or focus on the work it helps you
it helps the thing get done right yeah
because uh because when we started we
also for some reason had this idea that
we got to post a video a week and we
were so strict on that and I don't even
know where he came from we just had this
you mean back yeah I think it was just a
personal thing it was like it's what
kept me motivate you said you can focus
forever on something you at a certain
point got a cut there's so many reasons
why I love the speed and the schedule so
many reasons it's life or death I mean
this well that's not true because some
of them were done without a schedule and
they need it to be but when I'm off
schedule
I get obsessed with schedules and I
start watching behind the scenes
Seinfeld documentaries one six days to
air that's just incredibly I even get
addicted to like how stressed out they
get I'm just like you know not that
that's good you romanticize them yeah I
I what well yeah I mean I am whenever
I'm not on a schedule I I get so
obsessed with being on a schedule yeah
because it goes on forever you can't you
know especially I mean if you're
perfectionist I mean I'm kind of a
raging perfectionist so you know there's
there yeah it'll go on forever
what was that quite you said you're a
perfectionist and that's mark to me yeah
I meant that Ellis know that she thought
was wonderful and I was like it was like
strep question because we have a
question thread that we put on our
subreddit okay well to so many questions
for you and there was a question there
that was my favorite and it was how did
you kill perfect
well yeah you can use a steamroller or
bulldozer it becomes incredibly
important to do that when you have it as
badly as I do you from you're never
gonna get anywhere unless you have a
serious strategy for steamrolling right
/ perfection so you so you start to do
there's one at it called Monday a good
fire truck which is like that's probably
I think hit the mark the best in terms
of flattening perfectionism just like
just just mash it and that that
satisfies you when you smash your
perfection is yeah if it means you can
get something done instead of not yeah
yeah and after you create a work do you
look back and see like oh I could have
done this different that's ever that's
in the past and it's time to move
forward no yeah interesting and so scary
the schedule defeats the perfectionism
when you hit your schedule that's it
well it doesn't defeat the perfectionism
but it it's like a too long yeah you
know you get beat up you get there and
you get stronger oh my god the thing I
mean it's being to which the vine thing
when I ran out of vines had to do them
fast and then I was doing started doing
a history of Japan and so I flipped my
schedule around and I started doing
history first in the earlier in the day
and then just wait until the last two
hours to do to do the vine it was crazy
I had some crazy times and I was you
know I learned so many new tricks and
techniques that I never would have
learned if I didn't have to you know
crunch down yeah because you're most
productive in the morning start like
your strongest hours because you said
you did that history in the morning and
know the reason for that I was trying to
get ahead of the schedule with with the
vines but that never works because the
deadline is not there so I would spend
six hours doing one even though I
thought I was going as fast I can but I
wasn't so I just said okay look I need
to get this history thing happening
prioritize that do as much you can first
and then about four o'clock or something
just run for it and see what you can get
I'm fine yeah how many hours a day do
you work it sound you are incredibly
productive you're incredibly focused on
your work I can tell by the volume and
just and your website and your work has
so much detail and I mean how much do
you do
and as much as possible how many hours
and is possible but the problem is I
know what you're gonna say you're gonna
say you gotta take breaks and I was
going to say that but the problem is and
it's one
the problem is that when you work too
much yeah and then it starts [ __ ] all
of a sudden you can't get out of bed in
the morning or if you have relationships
or other things you want to do then you
are yeah but if you like what you do and
that's what gets you out of the bed then
work as much as you got am well pleased
yeah well I think I naturally tend to
take a break even though I want to admit
it like sometimes even if it's time
crunch crazy time crunch sometimes I'll
just go face down into bed just for 20
minutes just cuz I can't even just you
know boom face it down but but I can't
but yeah I mean I know it's like ya good
to take breaks but how long should the
breaks be and how often should the
breaks be you never what do you do well
I don't admit it
I never admit you walking a break that's
the problem I had that problem you know
what my problem is that I'll spend all
day working or I'll spend all day being
busy but then when I look back over the
day I never took a break necessarily
like where I'm like oh municipal it for
my work but somehow I was less
productive than I thought I wasn't
working the whole day I don't know when
I took breaks yeah I don't know I don't
know I don't have a strategy for that
really but huh but when the when things
take way too long as it is and and you
know you there's no time to lose you
know mm so yeah I gotta make sure do you
have hobbies outside of uh you know man
music luckily I've been able to sort of
incorporate most of them I'm trying to
incorporate all of them into you know
like anagrams I mean I used to just I
can't believe you so bill for context on
his website bill words calm is that
slash anagrams no yes people submit
sentences for you to anagram yeah and
you'll unscramble it and make a new
phrase yeah is that and some of them are
really incredible maybe you compose some
examples up down that we can read off
rope Oh God some of them are really
appropriate for mm-hmm oh well dad I saw
the family watching but they'll have to
endure for some reason it's it's very
tempting to make them dance sent me
something here look oh thank you for
your recent purchase was the submission
and bill turned it into try our corn
cake funhouse therapy and then another
one the joy of painting fight to enjoy
pain now what that is incredible that in
your mind you can anagram no it's not
it's not in my mind you know you can use
computers now
oh so you use like a website no but a
computer I know people are gonna say oh
you use computers but a computer won't
give you that look at a long run go get
a really long help me out here but so
what's your technique then how do you
hello Jesus I don't know if I can you
know but you just gotta okay let's see
let's see well if you have these in
there you need to find out where the V
is gonna go because otherwise it'll turn
up left over if you have you know you've
got to take care of the you gotta take
care of that and then you just try some
stuff and then also you know it's good
it's good if it relates to the thing
especially if it's a longer thing so if
you know try to try to think of what
words you're gonna need to relate and
just take care of that long ones are fun
because you can start out saying
anything you want because the letters
are gonna be there and then you get down
at the end like oh now I have like a
surplus of ends and L start over and try
to work some more into Nell's and what
is it about anagrams that fascinates you
that of yours yeah I started I went to
my friend's house at one point a long
time ago and he was rearranging Scrabble
tiles he's doing people's names and I
was just for some reason so I just went
home and started doing it and I've been
doing it you know ever since well I tend
to do like the things that are in my
life like if I would get a job I would
do the name of the job or do you know
and I just it's something I've done
throwing time and finally I was able to
integrate it into the I definitely
noticed in your videos and your lyrics
are very much kind of script you know
mixing up words and a lot of wordplay do
you when you plan your videos do you
plan out like how meticulously do you
plan out and how much is it I know
you've like remix jazz and you're kind
of a fan of jet or or you have music
where you remix and jazz right oh I
there's a lot of like Coltrane and stuff
yeah yeah yeah it's just like jam jam
it's like it's like when it's like the
way I mean jazz in that sense it's like
when a bunch of guys get together and
read standards like out of the real book
so what happens to be except it's just
me so what I mean is how much of is
improvised cuz it's it seems somewhat
random but very controlled so when
you're making a video do you make up
anything as you go or do you MIT or is
it completely planned out and then you
actually the visual would be kind of as
I go along
mm but in terms of what in terms of the
audio in terms of the words melodies the
exact chords and the timing of all the
anything that's spoken or sung and the
exact chords and the exact timing is all
written before that's written everything
else is just usually implied from there
and then I just fill in the space and
the underscoring sorry sorry that the
underscoring music so the extra little
instrumental stuff that goes in between
when I'm speaking that's all done after
that make sense sort of support what's
there and so you you do the music first
it sounds like V and build around nah
not that music but the debate anything
that's sung or spoken mmm I do that
first
the underscoring music is done after
interesting we've got a long one here
back to the anagrams here where does
this start okay supersonic game mega
percussion where does this start cringe
poems USA it's not long it's not long
[Music]
not that one I had oh I see if anyone's
just wondering the answer to that is
group is gruesome panics use more
spacing this is gape ism you're gone you
have choices I do so here we go here's a
long one
I hope doing these anagrams provide you
with an intellectual challenge that's
the submission and here's Bill's answer
guide me now as I get lunch pray to
religions and escape the hot lava inhale
that's it
that's incredible that you untangle that
yeah I think once you start once you
start doing them you'll see it matter
well no it's not you'll just you just
start to find stuff you do if you have a
high standard you know
you just have to just look and once you
start to get ones that are like that
good then you starts it like really get
excited is there anything interesting
and the fact that like this there's a
whole sentence with the alternative
meaning in that original one is there
something that fascinates you about just
which one like you're writing a whole
new thought just from this original one
yeah I wonder if that's a thread somehow
throughout your work I don't know mm-hmm
let's anagram that so history of Japan
when that came out that was an
incredible incredible explosion yeah so
popular yeah I mean right now I think it
has 43 million views but but that's now
I mean I think it had something like
just in the first week had like over 10
million views or something or even more
maybe it was yeah probably about 10
maybe after a couple weeks so surely you
were just blown away by yeah right yeah
because I was so tired of being stuck on
vine stuck under seven seconds like I
said I was like desperate to I was like
if only I could do this like so in a way
was a react because this was a really
epic undertaking and this was a reaction
to being like I hate doing the small
stuff I wanna do a huge I didn't hate it
I loved it and when I would sit down to
write a bunch of new ones I got really
excited every time but I I really wanted
to do you want something so tell me how
long did it take you to create that it
is 14 weeks wow that's incredible do not
people spend one day yeah but it paid
off and your camera it shows 14 weeks my
god tell me how did you you don't want
to know how long history the world took
well we do how did you decide on Japan
are you a are you a fan of Japanese
culture in any way well yeah but I I'm
not an expert really I mean I was during
for temporarily I did I wrote one for
the United States much earlier because I
wanted to do that you have the script
for us it never never got finished but
and it was going really well but it kind
of you know
I'd never done this before so I didn't
really know I was kind of falling apart
because I knew too much about certain
things and so yeah that didn't happen
but then so when I came around to try it
again I said I got to pick something
that I don't really know about interest
so that I can just learn about it from
beginning to end and then just spit it
out so it won't be you know just as a
challenge because if I can do that for
and I can do anything so that's that was
the idea there's almost a nice quality
to I think in there in the output when
you don't know anything like you said
you know so much about USA it kind of
models oh yeah I know too much about
some aspects yeah yeah and what is your
research procedure like because you know
so much about so many things like all
these little details
it seems so well researched and you've
got timelines and characters how do you
how do you lay that out I don't entirely
remember actually I mean I did it very
fast I mean like it took a long time to
make the video but I was scrambling so
how much time on research alone it I can
tell you that research and writing was
kind of together because I would just
learn a bunch of stuff and then write
just write I think that was about a week
I have the timeline oh I've posted the
timeline somewhere
so yeah something like that writing and
research is about a week and are you
read you're always I'm wondering do you
find people like nitpicking your facts
of course mm-hmm
does that bother you or you just like
and whatever oh yeah no yes and no I
don't know yes I did the best I could
yeah yeah of course yeah and it is
entertaining actually I'm surprised at
how few people do that okay so that's it
yeah well you're you know down of views
I mean I was really careful I mean I'm
obsessed with like geographical accuracy
like I saw the Japan video that I was
watching like to learn stuff and they
had Kyoto really in the wrong place it
was a cartoon drawing I was like that's
I don't know I'm just I'm kind of
obsessed with that well it showed it's
when I watch that you're like this is a
guy that knows what he's talking yeah it
kind of has that vibe so but when you
present yourself in that way there's
always people who are looking to like
find one thing to nitpick you know I
probably spend too long on those things
where I put the stars on
on the cities you know I remember one I
remember actually there was a early I
haven't seen that since it came out by
the way but I think there's an early
point where I'm showing where all the
old like clans are or the old they you
haven't watched the video have not seen
it since it came out why what what
flashbacks of what just thought yeah I
don't know I don't watch videos after I
make never not I try no exception
unless someone would like forces me to
but what I was gonna say is uh yeah I
probably spend too long on those ones
with the Stars
now when you say that you're like you're
kind of like that one was the millimeter
like that wasn't that one was difficult
cuz it's like ancient clans and stuff
like that or ancient you know ancient
locations like one is called high H I
how do you google that yeah it took a
long time yeah and there was one for
history the world where I show like a
million cities and I spent a long time
getting the exact coordinates all for
like half a second on screen so I don't
know what's wrong with me well you know
whatever and I think something's great
yeah yeah I think we've got it all
backwards I find it interesting that you
don't watch that video back I love it so
much that video is amazing it's it's
amazing it's got to feel good how I'm
almost prolific that video was how it
kind of reverberate it through a culture
it wasn't just YouTube it was on reddit
it was online it was everywhere as on
television I mean there were everybody
did you see it on regular television I
must have I don't I must have I think
people the way I remember is people were
watching it I remember black Joe Rogan
was watching it and talking about it it
just was so prolific and its influence I
mean that's this mark of this insane
quality that you brought to it that
nobody really none of your
contemporaries are really doing and I
see you smiling there that's too kind
that's too kind well I think it's
amazing I think you're incredible I
think you're a gift I love that part by
the way when the new Oh Dan just found
it on CNN bill
is it on CNN you want that's on there
one other YouTube check it out oh yeah
must've cover it at some point no words
on television baby I love this moment my
favorite moment with the hiroshima he
does this for those of you who haven't
seen and I mean most I'm sure all of you
have history of Japan when the u.s.
drops the bomb on Japan and the video is
very manic it's super fast paced it's
very dense
and then all the sudden the bomb drops
and then it's just like yeah and another
one and it just gets quiet for a long
time because of the manic nature of the
video it makes that moment so powerful
yeah that's been a long time getting
that sound hmm
layering you know the windy sound and
the huge bass sound and just really feel
yeah it's like what explosions a lot of
layers in that it's like a drum and then
it's pitch pitch way down now was there
you you nailed that so beautifully
did you read was there something in your
research like that informed that when
you were just you felt the gravity of
that I know that obviously you know
obviously it's heavy but like yeah I
feel like there was a real expression
there a real empathy there from what I
heard they dropped a bomb and destroyed
a couple of like entire cities so that's
that's a big deal that's a big yeah yeah
that is a big deal well I love that
mm-hmm and you you touched on it again
in history of the world a really
beautiful way to what was it oh I did a
game yeah it was a yeah the game show
thing it's fun because I got to hit the
same it's kind of like Back to the
Future to hit some of the same things
but do it a little bit differently yeah
yeah actually the most fun part was
doing the viewing like the video game
soundtrack music for that for that
section you play video games anymore no
tie game I play now is the one where
game where I make videos yeah I guess if
more people thought about life as a
video game there might be more
[Music]
that's a shower thought well we're on
our first break when we come back I have
I want to talk about so much more the
incredible bill words I read I want to
apologize I'm terrible at doing
interviews I'm sorry no I so - I mean
this is I don't get our first interview
Oh God yeah of this sort yeah well yes
let me say that trusting us with that
experience of you come in here means a
lot to me I appreciate that I think
you're doing great and I'm fascinated by
everything you're saying so let's go to
a quick break we will be back after this
with Bill warts don't go away
here's a product that I wish I had when
I was a kid
candid okay they make these incredible
invisible braces that you order out they
measure your teeth they send it to you
at home they go on they look clear you
can't even tell you're wearing braces
and it fixes your frickin teeth I was
walking around metal in my mouth I think
it ruined your life this is so much
better this is the future candid
have you ever had a problem with your
teeth that you've always wanted to fix
I've got an option that can help you you
won't need to go through the hassle or
long-term treatment of wired braces aka
life-ruining torture and you can do it
all from the comfort of your own home
it's a new company called candidate by
the way you can pop them out and into
like when you're eating huh I mean this
is so much better
candy makes clear aligners that are sent
directly to your home and are customized
specifically for you to straighten your
teeth by the way this is what they look
like they don't know if you show on the
screen
the aligners fix crooked teeth crowding
protrusion and gaps the first step is to
purchase their modeling kit which will
be sent to your home so you can take
impressions of your teeth and after you
send back your impressions with some
photos of your teeth candids networks of
orthodontists review your specific case
and provide you with the 3d preview of
what your treatment will look like we're
having a real orthodontist is the main
reason you're gonna love candid because
other companies
use dental professionals whatever the
heck that means
am i right they wrote that I don't know
after you receive your 3d preview it's
completely up to you if you want to move
forward with your clear aligning
treatment plan or not and you can always
talk to a real person at any time if you
have any questions they have a great
customer support
white-glove they said whatever that
means white gloves their customer
support wears white gloves guys if
that's good for you or not I don't know
I prefer without gloves personally and
here's the best part
candidates treatment time is an average
of six months I think I had mine for
like two years I had mine for six months
oh well you know you're really good six
months and will literally save you
thousands compared to the other guy I
did have mine for like two years so
you're one step away from getting
straight in whiter teeth I think one did
they white I guess they waiting them - I
don't know that take advantage of
candidates risk free modeling kit
guarantee plus when you use my dedicated
link candid koat.com slash h3 you'll
save 25% on the modeling kit that's
candid koat.com slash h3 to get 25% off
the price of your modeling kit candid
koat.com slash h3 listen up your
bald-headed goofs alright this one's for
you if your hair is falling out if
you're in the shower you see that like
cycle your hair going down the drain
listen 66% of men lose their hair by age
35 the thing is when you start noticing
your hair's going it's already too late
it's a way easier to keep the hair the
beautiful hair that you've got on your
head than it is to replace the hair that
you've already lost okay I know that
hairline is slowly moving backwards like
the like the setting tide like a low
tide that never comes back in you got
some bald spots how do you feel year
from now when it's busy when it's
business as usual up there I ask you
let's get rid of those bald spots let's
do something about it let's get that at
that receding uh ocean line to come back
in the tide comes back in that's right
yeah let's get a tsunami on your head
for hips calm a one-stop shop for hair
loss skincare and sexual wellness for
men thanks to science thanks to science
baldness is optional
hymns connect you with real doctors and
medical grade solutions to treat your
hair loss we got well known generic
generic equivalents to name-brand
prescriptions to help you keep your hair
okay guys this is prescription solutions
backed by science there's no waiting
room no awkward in-person doctor visits
you can save hours by going to four hems
calm and you're gonna keep that
beautiful luscious head of hair and be
the God that you are answer a few quick
questions
doctors will review and prescribes you
the products that you need directly to
your door so listen up order right now
my listeners you get a trial of a month
trial hems for just five freaking
dollars today right now or all supplies
last so see the website for full details
this will cost you hundreds of dollars
and so much time if you went to a doctor
pharmacy so go to forums comm /h 3
that's fo r hims com /h 3 for team Cobb
slush
when you think of the perfect gift you
probably don't think of an electric
toothbrush but guess what you should
because quip is one of the most gift
gotted gifts of the season and this is
why ok they've got a sonic vibration
gentle enough on your sensitive gums and
built-in timer with guiding pulses to
remind you when to switch size to make
sure you get that thorough toothbrush
that you need quip is the gift that
keeps refreshing brush heads
automatically are delivered on a dentist
recommended schedule every three months
just for 5 dollars and you can even get
a gift prepaid refill for a year to make
sure that they never get old worn out or
ineffective bristles quip is one of the
first electric toothbrush accepted by
the Dental Association and as thousands
of five-star rated reviews I love quip
because it's just it's so convenient
it's so tight I get the quality of a
much more expensive electric toothbrush
you know dentists say electric is the
best way to brush boom boom it tells you
exactly what you need and your mouth is
going to thank you for it just try this
sweet little baby that's why I love quit
looks like it's a big tip big ticket
tech gift but it starts at just $25 so
go to get quip comm /hc right now and
get your first refill pack for free with
a quick Alan quick electric toothbrush
but you don't have to tell your giftee
that
that's your first refill pack free at GE
tqu IP comm / h3 now through - ah now
through December 25th now through
December 25th the Tulalip now through
December 25th the 23andme DNA kits are
on sale 23 me helps you understand what
your DNA can tell you about you and your
family's story it's named for the 23
pairs of chromosomes that make up our
DNA 23 ma DNA kit is the perfect gift
for anyone you love and there's never
been a better way to give the gift of
genetic discovery to your parents
siblings aunts or grandparents and
everyone else on your list it's the one
gift that you can buy the entire family
and it will be unique for every loved
one you got the 23andme health and
ancestry service which includes - 90
plus personalized genetic reports that
offer DNA insights on what makes you
unique it's easy to do all you do is
spit in a tube which is the fun and sexy
as part of your day and 23andme kit
registers your sample to your personal
23 me account in a few weeks you receive
your personalized online report here are
some of the things that you can discover
just a couple from analyzing your DNA do
you like the taste of cilantro I've
heard people say that it tastes so P
which I found was blew me away cuz I
love cilantro Mexican food yeah
apparently that's genetic you can find
out if you have an aversion to cilantro
how about this your ability to match
musical pitches genetical you can see in
their DNA how about this one
misophonia they say that right everyone
hates noises like nails on a chalkboard
but for some people the reaction can
incite rage or panic let's christen
something mosquito bites how frequently
do you get bit by mosquitoes this always
and so much more you can find out from
this report just from spitting out a
little tube and sending it off in the
mail now due December 25th get 30% off
any 23andme kit order your DNA kit at
23andme comm /h Lee that's the number
203 a and D me.com slash h3 again 23 me
comm / h3 welcome back everybody here
with Bill warts
I want to ask you about history of the
world I guess but before that I am
curious to ask you about
you have this very unique aesthetic
style and me as a video editor myself I
am captivated by your editing style it's
incredible
how'd it where did you how did you
develop that style I don't know I I'm
just trying to get a you know be
reasonable really I mean I'm just trying
to do it do what needs to be done you
know get the job done and unfortunately
it's like the only way I can do it
really and some people say everything
looks too much the same which is I don't
know how I'm gonna avoid that because
you know what how is that the only way
you can get it done because it seems
like there's a lot of effort that goes
into the visual quality like you've got
this kind of neon psychedelic yeah and
it's like multi-layer well you know the
art you'd write you do all the art and
the videos or a lot of most people's
clipart right right right which is kind
of yeah well I got a graphics thing when
doing history of the world because I
wrote all this stuff about space and
stars and then you're gonna have like
what are you gonna do so I got a kind of
graphics tablet so that's how cool I can
draw yeah that's helpful too bad I can't
really you know I feel long way to go
there but you know it's great I mean
that's great it's very specific style
but do you what what do you add it and
can I ask that just says I'm a curious
editor myself well I'll give you a hint
it's I'm screwed and a lot of a lot of
people are in work I don't know if
anyone's stayed screwed for this long if
yeah there was a popular program that
was industry standard I know they made
another one with the same name but it's
a different program so and I'm sure it's
fine most people hated it x10 whatever
most people hated it when it came out
then they badmouth it I trust that it's
gonna be okay cuz the other option is
the one that you have to pay every month
yeah I can't do that so so yeah I trust
that it's gonna be okay I'm going to
switch but there's never a good time to
relearn everything I know every week I
learn a new thing on the thing that I'm
using and I've had I mean if you want to
know what it looked like go back to the
first Monday video on the five day
schedule I think it was about a pelican
or something and it's nothing it's like
text and nothing well the truth is I
mean you are using what was considered
history standard it's not even that it
is the light light version of them it's
missing I don't know what but I've never
seen it so I don't know what I mean you
got eight yeah the truth is uh I'm
looking forward to switching but I just
I know cuz like we added and I feel like
with every upgrade they've actually
added some stuff there so sometimes
they'll just break the software yes and
that right how was it treat some stuff
are saving us so much time what's the
new mask and what if you know anything
about final cut 10 yeah I know I used to
final cut but not 10 so that's the new
one you have to pay for there's other
one that you're using X is the one that
X is what replaced so which is what
you're talking about
I've literally only met one person ever
that like Dex everybody else well see
I've heard the same rumors but I have
found at least two or three people that
say yes it's fine don't worry it's
getting better it's getting better they
say they're adding back all the things
and it's like the one I have is not even
the one that you think I have it's worse
than so you can do you can do it on
anything it's not a zero in time with it
and that's one of the reasons I don't
like to go around saying what program I
use I know people are just eager to buy
a thing and I think they're gonna get a
bill you know that's a that's a good and
they won't get that yeah and that's true
of kind of any art craft if you have
like a sick guitar yeah or an amazing
computer or whatever is the tool that
you use you have to master yeah your
craft and here's another thing helps if
you get really crazy software before you
know how to use it it will it will ruin
you and it I mean I've been I've been
there you know I've done that and and
you get frozen for four years you just
don't even touch the thing because you
don't know what to do so intimidating
and yeah not intuitive those these
programs are not intuitive at all well
they might be but it takes time to learn
it's like yeah yeah interesting I think
that's good that's a good advice for
people who are trying to learn things
just get in there and do that first then
worry about the tools and you just gotta
I just you gotta use simpler tools I
mean you gotta just use what you have
use what's available and you know you'll
go really far and then by the time
you're ready to you know then one by one
step by step you can get
yeah but the so did you develop this
visual aesthetic with like the tidal
fonts that you use and all that is that
something that you just started with or
yeah I'd is that something you developed
or I'm just trying to get by yeah yeah
it does develop over time if you want to
see what it was I mean you know go back
to Monday pelican or whatever the heck
that was yeah nothing and then gradually
just a little bit more and then when I
started doing vines every day and really
fast it kind of accelerated I mean I
started learning all kinds of that's
cool
so let me ask you still learning stuff I
mean now I'm on a really tight schedule
and I'm learning more and more and more
all the good I'm learning so much about
editing I was I did what you said not to
do and it was to my detriment because
ice learned how to edit on premiere
which is like the industry standard on
PCs and you when you don't know what
you're doing and you don't know the
right tools it's you're so freaking slow
and it's taken so long to catch up like
I was working with an editor we had
hired just a couple months ago Alex we
get great kid I don't I call him a kid
that's like he's a sweetheart he's a
great kid
and he taught me like a couple of little
key shortcuts that like changed my life
like it's literally saves me hands of
hours I have this crazy thing I mean
there's a lot of in the thing I use
there's a lot of things that don't don't
have shortcuts so it drives me crazy but
there's a trick I use on a Mac if you
command question mark it opens up the
help menu and then you can type the
first two or three letters of what you
need so it's like eight strokes but I do
it anyway oh you got a shortcut for the
shortcut yeah like I mean I have all
this like I said that's why I'm going to
be so screwed if I have to switch cuz
it's like I keep finding new little
tricks and inventing like new tricks and
you when you edit are you on the laptop
or a computer and you use a mouse oh my
god
you know I had one of those nice I had
one of those nice trackpads on the side
yeah but the the batteries like leaked
and it got the door that the battery
door got stuck that aint usual I could
not get it open it was like I mean I
couldn't get I cannot edit on a laptop
you know I met a man without a mouse I
mean the thought of that is unbelievable
and it's a testament to your genius and
dedication but I will say if I were
genius I'd probably get something better
but again the problem is we're all
screwed because if you go to a system
higher than whatever the one High Sierra
was the one where it officially stopped
working so what the program doesn't work
anymore I know you're limited but I'm
gonna well I'll say this
you run I knew a kid you may not know
anything I'm talking about but it
reminds me of this for all of you who
have ever played World of Warcraft or a
serious video game do you play video
games world Warcraft do you know about
any of those stuff I don't have time to
do anything except make okay
unfortunately was a very intense video
game that's played with a mouse and a
keyboard and I have a friend who clocked
thousands of hours was in the highest
level of raiding of collaborating with
40-plus people high level raids and I
played with him a lot I was good friends
with him and one day I went to his house
and I saw this kid on a laptop without a
mouse and I didn't know it was possible
I was absolutely blown away he was
playing a high level game with a
trackpad on a keyboard blew me away
and I thought this man is a he's
incredible
and I haven't this I have this
admiration for you to edit without a
mouse is truly a feat it's probably not
smart it's probably not smart so the
desk that I anyone who supports me on
patreon is gonna get so mad because I
you know so I'm not spending money on
have a desk that is 10 years old and
cost $10 probably where'd you get it
no the convenience store pharmacies
doing those pharmacies
now you you and you bring up an
interesting point you are supported
primarily through your patreon is that
correct no it's it's a combination of of
things yeah but that's a that's a big
piece of the puzzle
so patreon by the way if you guys want
to support bill I'll put it in the
description patreon.com slash bill words
right yeah and I have to apologize you
know for my lack of social skills intact
and everything but thank you to anyone
who has like never you know my patreon
is blank it is blank and I've never said
you know it's like really promoted no no
but they are helping like pay my rent
essentially so yeah thank you for that
well I think that's fair when we were
starting off we had a patreon and we
also had a blank because I don't I think
that's the point right because they want
you focusing on what you do and not
necessarily trying to make gifts and not
central for people not sure that's how I
saw it no it's just like thank you for
supporting me we can continue to do what
we do which is apparently what you want
moral right so I think that's perfectly
fine I hope so and Marie and and recent
very reasonable because I didn't have
one and everyone said you know geez why
don't you at least make one just so
people know and but is it true that you
turn off ads on your YouTube video not
entirely I had them off for a long time
and then I realized that if you want to
get the red income from that you have to
it lower you the way they have it Wow
uncheck every box except for display ads
which is the one that puts a picture on
the side because when I see ads it like
really when I see them that like really
makes me uncomfortable
really yeah so so but I have that on
there and I know you know you're gonna
be mad at me for not a lot of people are
mad at me for not having the video
pre-roll video ads on like the history
videos but I don't I figure so so you
never really had a big payoff from those
big big Japan in history world I did
because through the other things the
YouTube Brad stuff know through patreon
and there's a PayPal donate thing oh so
a lot of people responded it directly
support yeah oh well god bless that's I
mean I'm really happy to hear that
I think so yeah thanks to those people
whom they are I support you on patreon
you just did this morning I was and we
didn't know that you don't promote it
yeah well I figure you were just making
money like the rest of us but here you
are like working your ass after an
amazing content yeah the thing is
certain I won't even mention the name
but certain web companies and stuff like
are stalking me if the rest of my life
through through targeted ads like
interests and you know and it's like I
can't even I can't put other people
through that bother you know that people
follow you on the internet trying to
sell you [ __ ]
yeah become mean at targeted ads yeah
it's just really annoying it's good
strategy you know and this might help
you be at ease with putting ads on your
videos you have an option as a YouTube
creator to turn off targeted ad that's
true that's true I don't know if that
helps you I might because I do want you
to prosper and to make money so I don't
know but that is that the primary reason
you you don't run ads on your videos
it's just a drag you know for the viewer
and I'm plenty of people always tell me
no it's not people I say you know no
it's not you know they say we don't mind
but they can't speak for everyone some
people but DV what do you think about
the fact that like everybody on the um
how do you say the expected experience
is that there's an ad there you know
like television or any popular medium
cuz how how are you expected that's a
good point because that's a good point
cuz maybe the reason I haven't done it
I'm trying to psychoanalyze this cuz I
really I always should yeah you should i
I do think you should and so I'm you
know what it is I remember when there
were no ads on YouTube but YouTube was
like there's no way they can't put ads
on YouTube it's the Internet you know
ads are for the TV you know and then I
remember the first day I saw an ad on
YouTube then I felt like the outrage you
know so I guess it's been a long time
since then but I still it's you that
outraged lives yeah even though maybe
shouldn't anymore but look but look at
you you are extremely hard-working
talented your life for your work as you
say I don't have time to do anything
else because I'm working so this is not
some dude posting vlogs or [ __ ]
around a hobby I mean this is your life
this is your work I mean you're entitled
to get paid for that work and an
addition to patreon which is completely
optional the people can support you
their call so as an artist you I say
like your your work is your art and you
put it up there for free and you know
like if you I don't already sell their
work so you put it out up for free so at
least you could get money that way but
not to press you not to press I say that
5mu sell things too but it doesn't work
that well nowadays cuz with the internet
you sell it to one person and then they
can send it to everybody else oh you
sell duck digital media well I sold
music but I mean it's also on the
streaming sites so just pay for that I
guess alright I guess there's ads there
so technically there are ads so you know
but in the internet you know it's like
it's kind of you know selling stuff on
the internet it's kind of not entirely
real I mean you can sell it to the first
person you could charge a billion
dollars for the first one but then once
one person has it they could they could
just send it to anyone well what do you
think about what looting did they had
that that was a relly better Miller I
was that I was thinking that uh I mean
that's that's like yeah they did it
that's ten as far as I know nobody's
heard that element of Martin shkreli
still that's too bad it is too bad it
needs a prison you can't do anything
with it now probably an evidence bin
somewhere I had heard that he had played
a portion of it on his stream really you
know I cannot believe that album was
sold for only a million dollars it's
whoo tang like how did nobody pay more
than that Martin shkreli is the only guy
who willing to shell out Amelie for that
yeah you would think like someone like
jay-z or you know maybe someone who's
like really the guy some money there
would Aang anyway I still haven't
figured out what it mean what it means
to sell stuff on the internet and what
you know because you know yeah I just
looked it up and apparently that album
is now in the hands of the government
they seized
[Laughter]
they ever imagined their million-dollar
album would end up in the hands of the
government
well people maybe they'll add it to the
Library of Congress hey there you go
they should I'm Sonia that's so funny
so do you what do you consider that well
how do you consider that act by wu-tang
to have this one CD is that cool
theoretically what I thought was a legit
thing but I still have not really
figured out what I think about that
because you want people to hear you do
exactly so that's why you wanna yeah
it's caught it's interesting and
strengths but anyway not to persuade you
about the ad thing I only am looking out
for your best interest and I want you to
prosper and I think you'd be surprised
by how much that can that can add to
your your bet your quality of life for
Christ's sake yeah I might do it I mean
do you do you have any idea how much
money those two videos alone would be a
lot I people have deemed me on Twitter I
mean hundreds of saying well no people
have I used to get DMS on Twitter saying
we'll pay you I won't tell you how much
money but we'll pay you this much money
for you to just turn over the rights to
the ads viral hog oh my god that's so
funny like viral people that wanted to
buy the ads right now someone someone
said will give you you know made a huge
consume you know for for just the ad
sales rights and have you had like
sponsors well any interesting people
come in rolling through your email
interesting opportunities yeah anything
interesting that you're working on then
usually the most usually the most
interesting ones have these long
disclaimer at the end that says you
can't talk about any of this no I'm not
asking you don't have to talk about it
but that's cool to know that you're cool
yeah that's awesome
yeah that's exciting I can't wait to
find out whatever that is well I've said
no to a lot of most of them or a lot of
them or I mean I'm notoriously bad at
collaboration collaboration
well that's good at least I was hoping
that people would have recognized kind
of what's going on with you and because
I well what is your what is your
aspirations are you feel like you've
arrived on YouTube or what is your dream
I'm gonna take take over the world maybe
take over the world you want to be the
dictator no no I don't know
you wanna make a movie you wanna make a
cartoon you want to make it animator
well hopefully something like better you
know
mmm I would I would freaking die to have
like a history of like that as a show
would be absolutely captivating I want
to do that too the problem if that's
what I wanted to do the problem is it
takes so long to make but you would work
with people is that something right I
know I know that would be how to do it
you could have a team of 20 people you
know just you can make one every month
or you can make the whole 10 way already
doing it we already got a show it's just
slow we don't get an episode every week
is that okay or would you be happy to
see it accelerate is what okay
oh the rating yeah never was that's why
yeah well it's been a wrong way wrong if
you could what what's like the perfect
rate of releasing those in your ideal
world history videos yeah what's a week
is that enough time to do all the
research here's the problem then I did
the entire world just because I figured
let's escalate how do we beat Japan and
after doing that I don't look I'm really
interested in history or I was I mean
I'm really like really you know and
after doing that like I don't want to
say another word about history ever
again oh really
yeah so you don't want to make the
history series I did it was the only
thing I wanted to do for a long time and
then I did I just not that I said
everything in that in fact that was the
most painful part was because the more
you learn the more you find out how much
you're gonna have to leave out like 99%
yet
yeah yeah that was painful but I assume
so are you not working on another
history video right no not right now no
I'm doing songs okay every is there some
long-term project in the background that
you're working on no but I think there's
about to be no yeah because I just got
to the B I think there's about to be you
found a topic or something to fascinates
you or you don't
yeah I can't yeah okay cool yeah well I
know that every I everybody loved
everything you put out is adored would
those those specific works are just like
I mean they're like they're modern
masterpieces and it's like everybody
just can't get enough of that I mean you
cannot get people on YouTube to what how
long is the history of the world it's
like for like 19 I was hoping it would
be five because I didn't that time to
take another three months off like you
know so I was like okay bye verse 5 to 7
and then I was right I was writing it
after two months I was still writing not
making the video I was researching
writing after months three months and
it's at 12 minutes and it's like reading
at 14 yeah it's just you got to turn ads
on dude so how long did it take you
total would be 11 months
oh we're I don't recall were you gone
during that whole time just like what do
you mean were you posting videos no I
was like it wasn't done but I mean on
your YouTube channel right I didn't post
it no there was nothing oh wow yeah it
was rough every single day you wake up
to like everyone's saying probably and
like gone from the yeah but you came
back big time well I never left when you
posted well I mean in that kolenda
mental collective of the world so to
speak yeah so let's move on to the
history of the world then because that
video now if I let's see that video the
history of the world I guess has 55
million views and sits on our videos
number two of all time with hundred and
seventy-six thousand of us do you use
reddit but do you understand kind of how
nuts that is so when you posted that
video what was your expectation
station for the reception well it was I
knew Japan did that it was number one
and read it notice them so I was like
okay this could and it's a huge
escalation from the Japan video it's
like the ultimate thing mm-hmm so I was
like okay this could really get there
but you just can never get yeah which is
scary I've been you know working on this
for a year yeah you know I was thinking
at the end of it was like I never want
to spend this long I'm very thankful
that they came through and so what was
that like for you when you finally that
must have been utterly relief i relief
somebody told me somebody texted me and
they said it's number one year it's
number just like thing I was just
relieved spend that long you know you
don't and are you happy with how it came
out that video yeah I guess I mean I
haven't watched it since it came out so
I think it's okay there's plenty of
things that are just way undercooked I
mean look it went through like you know
within the first four months and
something I started working on the
graphics and stuff like that I was I
mean I must have spent all day looking
for images of different like apes I must
have spent all day looking at apes at
finding that perfect clipart yeah and
then I was like what am i doing it
occurred to me that this is gonna take
multiple years to finish if I don't
seriously kick myself faster every day
so it really just became again and again
and again I had to just pick myself up
and just go faster so that kind of goes
back to the whole issue of deadlines
because you're such a perfectionist when
you remove that deadline it can probably
drive you crazy yeah I mean but you know
I mean around October I set a deadline
of December 1st I was like this during
October November I was kicking ass I was
like working so fast but it came around
to December and I wasn't nearly done and
then I just couldn't get out of bed for
too much by the way it didn't get done
to make way you said you can't you
couldn't get out of bed you mean you
were just despaired just like working so
hard I was just like you needed a very
is your your night are you like up to
the point of like you're not even
sleeping that much no I do sleep I see
you good sleeper how much sleep you
sleep I sleep 10 hours it'll be like
nine or ten yeah god bless you unless
now I'm on a schedule and unfortunately
toward the end of the schedule
it gets ridiculous toward the deadline
etiquette you set an alarm clock
no god bless you too do I know I know if
for me but that one joy being
self-employed is not setting alarm clock
I mean that's that's all that matters
for me a problem is I tend to drift
telling you personal things but I sleep
schedule drifts forward like an average
about that or a day like it on average
like rotating so yeah I'll sometimes
wake up at like 3:00 a.m. well any time
it'll it'll it'll keep drifting if I
don't have to if I don't have to work
for anybody else you know you know it'll
gradually drift so what's your sleep
schedule look like right now right now I
woke up early you're on our Lee money
but I mean I just released the that's it
I got it I got it and I find that so
interesting so do you find yourself more
productive at a certain time of day or
is it all just rotating it's all a blur
doesn't matter that much what time it's
what kind of food do you like you order
I would sell your food is weird I don't
like to talk about food you'd only talk
about food food is weird not that into
food it's good we all do it we I mean
certainly that is a require I don't find
it that strange I love food you could
tell by looking at me
I'll eat all day and he looks pregnant
and she's you know we can we can not
talk about food I mean I don't have that
much save I don't unfortunately that's
interesting though doesn't really love
food hmm
but she's pregnant now and she's turned
into like a I want to say a beast mode
which I love I don't I mean that is a
absolute compliment because I'm a
monitor and she hardly eats so now for
the past three nights in a row we've had
pizza at last night I was eating pizza
with eel and I was like this is the
happiest I've ever been
each thrown yeah I usually don't care
about pizza but you don't have a
preference you don't like specific foods
yuck pizza
okay I don't really um reason I don't
really like to talk about food he lists
that way what about a are you a coffee
drinker yeah yeah nice I Scott
I just sugar cream I just really know
what I don't like - I really don't like
to talk about preferences of like what
okay what different people leader in
general released for me okay okay let me
yeah but I will say that yeah hot coffee
I just can't I can't
it it's it's it burns me physically
really I know you're sensitive to the
temperature yeah interesting like I
don't know I just you drinking you're
like oh no I'm burnt burn like for the
few days well my brother's very
temperature sensitive yeah he he can't
eat like until it's like lukewarm at
hottest has this explosion popularity
since these last two videos do you get
recognized on street ever well I mean I
mean sorry of those those big to I feel
like really put you do you get
recognized on the street ever does that
happen to you maybe does happen
sometimes and do you has this popularity
affected your life in any way or you
feel like everything's the same it's
weirdly the same alright because before
I had it I was pretending that I did mmm
just convenient cuz now I don't have to
change a damn thing it's like when I was
posting five times a week on the website
and I had it all like that you know I
didn't even tell anyone that I was doing
that I was just carrying on like
pretending that it was really important
and they do have a day job what was life
like or you were making money from your
art music oh music stuff like gigs and
stuff cool yeah god bless I'm just
wondering have you gone - you seem are
you classically trained with music I
sort of no no but I figured out sort of
the grapevine like the names of stuff
like the names of the notes and the core
isn't self-trained oh yeah completely
really and what was your first
instrument the keyboard
it was piano and drums and back the
piano back to drum back the piano
interesting who are your music
inspirations what kind of music do you
like but you have a very specific style
and you know and and and you know that's
that's unfortunate because you know I I
wish I could I'm just trying to do do
whatever I can you know you know it's
like if you have a green tractor and if
that's the one you have people say why
do you like to drive do you listen to
music though cuz yeah your whole life is
music you're right it is what are you
listening to these days unfortunately
there's not that much time but you have
a favorite artist no I don't I don't
break it down you like the Beatles well
I don't I even like really break it down
by artist cuz it's a every single artist
is gonna have stuff that I really love
and that I don't like and I think it's
that way with everyone maybe it's not
even by song like by song there's parts
of the song that I love parts of it that
I don't even individual moments of songs
so you Swan that's funny there reminds
me of kind of what Jason dunkey said he
doesn't this this blew me away
he says he'll take songs that he loves
and cut out the parts he likes I mean
cut out the parts and doesn't like and
then make a cut of his perfect idea in
that song I've done that really I
changed the two I cut up the bridge to
pretty woman and changed it it's great
tuned for some reason the bridge just it
it takes this detour it really bores the
hell out of me so I just without adding
anything new I just took the me pardon I
pitched it up a whole step and another
whole step and comes back around were
you always interested in music or was
that kind of him keeps coming back I
think by the time I was about 10 I just
liked it which is one of those things
that kept coming back mmm better do this
then yeah is there is there an artist or
bandur style where you think like that's
like what was it was there something you
ever heard as a child or whatever where
it was kind of transform you're like I
want to make music cuz this is just so
brilliant yeah I was probably a bunch of
stuff I don't remember exactly I don't
know can you hear those there's there's
there's sirens outside the sound
proofing can only do so much
there's actually a window behind that
foam you know Paul Desmond sax playing
on take five it's a very famous tune
mm-hmm I mean he doesn't nice job on
that real good I mean I heard that at a
young age good so that's jazz I don't
know yeah yeah sure Dave Brubeck people
but yeah I don't know that's a weird
thing to talk about now people are gonna
think oh I know
so dude you don't know no pressure I
don't know why I'm so you don't know you
don't stay I get the sense you don't
like talking about your musical
inspirations well that's not true but
I'm a little confused about what you
like or what about what you want to say
yeah I'm not sure I haven't figured it
out yet okay but one thing that I will
always come back to again and again it's
popular music hmm can't get away from it
really can't ignore it
you love to pop music I refuse to hate
it unconditionally mmm which I think it
seems like everyone around is always
doing it and I can't I well I think
that's I think that's a wise way because
clearly there's something there that
people find irresistible sure and pop
music you're right as always from the
times of like when I was a kid like
Backstreet Boys and Britney Spears or
whatever's popular yeah the the reaction
of everyone is always to be like
everyone new cool yeah but then you
start finding these articles and now on
YouTube you know you can see interviews
from 1955 from 1925 from you know for
any given year in the past everyone's
always trying to say that nothing is
good nowadays yeah and that the latest
technology is ruined everything once you
see how prevalent that viewpoint is at
every single moment in history suddenly
you just can't take it seriously anymore
you know why would it be true now if it
wasn't true then that's really that's a
really great obso it's just I have I
have no patience anymore for the pop the
unconditional pop hey think that's a
great great and I'm not saying I like
every tune that's ever on the radio but
man every given year and everyone has
different tastes but any given year if
you just check out the charts there's at
least a handful of tunes that are just
like yeah hmm you know I don't know and
it'll be different ones for different
people and maybe some people like none
of them that's fine maybe maybe that's
true but I just think it just never it
never stops you know 2014 2001 1952 I
mean sometimes I go to there's a charts
website where you can just listen to
stuff and you'll hear you'll hear a good
stuff and you'll hear people that are
copying their neighbors just trying to
sneak in there and that's always there -
mmm and that's cool I don't know I think
that's really wise it reminds me the
best example of that that I always hear
is like Bob Dylan when he switched to
electric everybody was like it's so
poppy and it's not authentic and
everyone was saying that he was a hack
and I was making pop music because you
swish the electric guitar maybe you
could say about Bob Dylan you can't say
that about anyone is do have a artist
today that you like a pop artist that
you're a fan of can't really I can't
really you don't like naming I can't
really say you know there's so many
things where and I don't even pay
attention like anymore like because
there's that there's certain songs
around like yeah I love that song I
don't sing but I don't even think about
whether or not it happens to be by the
same person another song that I can't
stand I just don't even notice anymore I
don't even interesting I would say when
I look at your style I will consider to
be almost psychedelic do you does that
influence on you at all no not not
physically not physically no but you
know what what do you mean do you take I
we were talking about this backstage you
kind of you have this Frank Zappa kind
of vibe I think about you with this like
really eccentric brilliant music and you
may know about free examples that
was very much not a drug user he was
very sober in fact to the point of even
expelling people from his band for using
drugs and that was during like the
sixties and seventies when everybody was
on drugs and I he was one of the most
eccentric and creative musicians from
that time period
do you really don't think I wouldn't do
I mean I wouldn't do that I wouldn't
kick people out you're not accessible it
was messing up yeah you're like dude
you're not good at yeah yeah or not
showing up to the gig
do you play in bands do you play music
with other people right now I just do I
just do solo yeah cuz you're very much a
one-man band as I understand from
watching your videos yeah but the but
the live the live show is gonna be a
band for sure oh we got a live show but
the thing no but the thing is it's gonna
be it's gonna be it's just gonna be a
band tell me about this live show what's
what is this it's not happening yet it's
not being yeah but you're planning yeah
well no I'm not for yet but I'm planning
to plan it you're planning planning
that's in the work and so I'm very
curious about this I think a lot of
people are this is a tour that you want
to do well like I said I'm not planning
it but I'm planning the planning okay so
um even got that far no and the problem
is while I'm doing it
I can't make a new any new songs or yes
but it can be lucrative
does that does money there's money
motivate you at all well it doesn't she
I hope it doesn't change what I do or
like how I do it so no I mean yeah I
mean I need it you need it I need some
of it yeah are you you don't care about
being a millionaire anything you just
want to keep doing what you know
there'll be convenient it'd be nice both
touring will be very lucrative I don't
know if you want to do it like that in
putting ads one would also be dude you
would be making I'll do it you're gonna
text me and be like thank you dude I'll
have to text a million people other
other people who he tells you sorry but
can I take credit for having convinced
you cuz this I feel like was no no cuz
you didn't convince me I'm not gonna do
I'm just saying you off my back okay
basically okay let's Google it's a good
honestly it's a smart idea I probably
should do it well uh yeah let me see
here
Oh you won that you won the shorty award
yeah how was that experience for you
because you went up there and just you'd
read her to thank you and you bounced
out it was too weird what was weird
about it well it's kind of alarming how
bad my social skills are like when I go
to a place like it knocked me out like I
didn't even you know I went to I got
invited this VIP fine party thing and it
was like I walked in and I walked right
out you just walked in I did it was like
at a bar with ping pong and stuff and it
was like a kindergarten flashback
because it felt like the whole room was
already talking and already knew each
other and I'm just like yeah there's
never a good time to go interrupt
someone and I just that awkward for
everything I think socializing I think
we all need to acknowledge how weird
socializing is it's so hard
hey hey guys playing ping-pong yeah can
I get next game yeah I mean we've never
gone to one of those I avoid em hmm
yeah but did woody you're alarmed by how
bad your social skills are I'm just
surprised I have like social anxiety no
no it's just I have no there's no word
anything once I'm in a conversation it's
cool as long as there's something to
talk about I was like yeah get that foot
in the door yeah so I pretty much of
those things I just literally get a beer
and stand somewhere just in the corner
just really and people who approach me
because they recognize me that's nice
that's very nice
and tell me about the awards ceremony
did you ever play ping-pong by the way
did you get a game no do you play
ping-pong I don't know oh no no I don't
you know what being gone it's not that
big of a deal yeah it's not that hard
it's not really that big I think it
actually is probably pretty hard it's
hard to be good at like Forrest Gump
good that's hard yeah but it's but
ping-pong is really not that serious
how was it accepting the award because I
was watching you had you you had this
great little video you put I guess on
your website but you never posted it on
on YouTube maybe it was on vine about
you being like I went up and I told her
keep the door open cuz I'm gonna be fast
yeah yeah yeah that was when I explained
pretty much half of what I just
explained actually yeah yeah tell me
about that acceptance what strategy were
you planning on that quick thank you
yeah I it was it was an option you know
cuz I saw like I said I saw Andre 3000
do it at the Grammys and he had a very
strong effect on me for some reason but
it's not it's not rocket science and
he's not the first person who's done
that I'm surprised more people haven't
done that well what more needs to be
said probably some more things could
have been said but I just didn't I just
didn't have it yeah just you know it
would be like the ceremony was going on
and I was like thanking thanking their
managers manager and their social media
manager and all this stuff I'd never
heard of but the detail that story that
I loved was that you're walking up to
the stage to accept the award and you
and there's a girl who's got her arm on
the door the and you want you were
planning in your head ahead you says I
don't want to be awkwardly waiting for
it alright open the door for me so he
says to her as he's going to guess where
he says I was pretty slick I love the
that we can see you saying it right in
the footage
[Laughter]
now was that something you were planning
while you were in the audience being
like if I win I don't be standing there
awkwardly yeah well you were brooding
over this I yeah I yeah as soon as I
walked in the theater I was just I was
all the way in the back too but I don't
know since we're just talking about how
you know antisocial and basing that's
okay okay I find it charming yeah I mean
it's genuine um I am very uh I feel like
I have social I feel like I need to draw
stuff I saw a Pharrell Williams
interview where he was just like do
doing stuff while he was interviewing
because I just couldn't deal with it
he's like
like thank you for interviewing me I
know I need to do interviews and it's
totally cool but just forgive me I just
have to you feel that way that you want
something you draw no do you feel it
that way and that's like you don't want
to do interviews but you feel like at
some point you have to yeah probably
yeah is this confronting kind of like a
I don't know if it's a fear but like a
necessity of you being here
yeah well it's fun too you know so cool
I mean I love I love having the
opportunity to speak to you your logo is
the umbrella what's the significance of
that well this is what happened really I
was doing I didn't on my website I had
no logo and I didn't really want one so
but then I was setting up the YouTube
channel and so setting up the banner so
I had the black background and it says
hi I think it still says this to this
day it said hi or something
so that was cool and then and then the
there's a thing in the corner where he
there's a thing you have to put in the
corner I was like okay well you got to
put something there so I just I just put
I did it based on what was already there
so the high thing is there yeah
so yeah I just picked what would look
good and then I realized that that's
actually gonna be the thing that shows
up as my thing which was a surprise to
me I didn't know I just thought it was
something was gonna go in the corner but
you know you're happy with the umbrella
yeah it's okay and I try to use a
different colour when I go to each
different platform do you have pet
peeves or things that annoy you
no I I don't know probably do but I
can't think of them right now what keeps
you up at night I don't know what gives
you most hope in the world this is you
have a list no it's all twists on you
yeah well I was doing history the world
research I sort of I already knew this
but I sort sort of got solidified in my
mind even more it was like the way
progress and discovery and things
getting crazier happens all the time you
know like it was just rocks
like billions of years and then
something more interesting and then it
was it's like for a long time and then
then something gets discovered and then
like you know hmm
so and that's been happening forever and
like faster and faster present but do
you think about the future in regards to
that stuff are you interested in like
robotics and yeah
Peter science and space and all that
stuff yeah it's probably gonna get
really crazy really fast
are you a man of Elon Musk do you follow
all that SpaceX stuff and Tesla I think
he's pretty cool but I I understand
there's some I don't know yeah I don't
know do you I love him I love him on mas
I love Elon Musk because I feel like
he's a cares a guy who is fabulously
rich he is one of the richest people in
the world and he uses his wealth and his
influence as intellect and my opinion
for the betterment of mankind and he he
has to do in a way that's profitable
obviously because how can you but SpaceX
which is basically just fueling his
fantasy of starting a colony on Mars
nearly bankrupted him as did Tesla the
guy's been on the verge of bankruptcy
from gambling everything he's got his
billions his vast wealth on these insane
ideas that everybody said it was
impossible
having a private company that sends
rockets in outer space
who would ever do that except the
government making electric cars zero gas
was batteries efficient enough to take
you through in German people said that
was impossible they I love him he's
incredible love him I don't know enough
to really yeah he's amazing but I I'm
fascinated by that rapid increase in
things I didn't even know I didn't even
really I feel like I didn't really
explain what Historic Site you said what
what am I hope it gives you hope yeah I
don't know I have it but I don't know
where it comes from
oh you you feel like you're naturally up
to me oh hell yeah yeah I feel like I'm
painfully Sinnott cynical do you think
I'm painfully cynical you but you feel
like you wake up generally have a sunny
disposition you're not
no no I've been worst morning anyone I
have morning anxiety I think yeah now I
have crazy morning anxiety so what does
that mean morning anxiety when you wake
up and you have crazy anxiety just
because of like of what what are you
anxious about or is it just a general
feeling so this show there's some Frank
well I don't blame you for that I mean
it's a new experience for you but just
like what you have to do that day things
are just yeah I think so
and when you got to have that eye opener
you know mm-hmm
once you get into your work you feel
more comfortable yeah once I figure out
what I'm doing and it's cool I feel like
that's most people it might be
I always wouldn't trust someone who
would telling me they'd just wake up
happy and like I felt pink yeah oh I'm
so thank God I'm alive that's kind of
how you should be right that's somehow
we're not maybe thank God
what a day of wonder that's like all
those self-help gurus are like every
morning I'm blessed that I'm awake I
think if you really care about doing
really good stuff and good work and
you've really care about making stuff
good there's gonna be a flip side of the
coin because you're gonna be really
paranoid that it's not gonna right kind
of have to yeah yeah a little bit and
hopefully it doesn't kill you do you
believe in UFOs or ghosts or do you
subscribe to any what would be
considered as conspiracy theories Wow
ghosts you know I thought ghosts were
pretty cool and I looked into some
things I found like some lists of like
all the most famous ghost sightings and
stuff I was kind of disappointed most of
them were not very believable I thought
I was going to find some really
believable stuff I've heard some stories
from people I know that are very
believable
I agree whenever I look in the ghost
stop because I'm I'm happy to accept a
natural skeptical person but I agree
that the the evidence is not not
compelling yet as of yet I thought I was
I was expecting to find it but I didn't
know what about UFOs and aliens do you
think aliens are out there well I think
alien just means someone from a
different planet than yours mm-hmm so I
think depending on what
planet you're on the other person would
be do you think there's interplanetary
beings that do you think there's beings
on other planets
of course and do you think they visited
the earth I don't know about that maybe
they have if but the thing is no no you
think there's intelligent cultural
beings out in the universe well yeah
there would have to be but but here's
the thing though we're gonna how long
have we been how long have we been here
really like yeah zero time this is one
of the things I was talking about things
are like going super fast like worth
here and we're mean I don't know what
the future is we'll either maybe be
extinct or maybe we'll invent an entire
way out of this entire paradigm somehow
or or invent our way off of this planet
or something I mean like so the chance
is that I don't know what I'm trying the
chances that there's another like that
we're the only I think what what what
you're what I think is that the chances
that we're the only ones here cooking on
this planet it's like lower than the
chances that there's other intelligent
cultural beings on other planets I would
think they would have to be but there
might to be right it might be pretty
quick it might be pretty temporary and
pretty quick before they like well what
fascinates me about our time on earth is
that it took a while to cook us up like
lighting on earth has been around for a
long time yeah and the dinosaurs were
cool they were dope but they weren't
really going anywhere
with science and [ __ ] like that so a
meteor was like our you know hard hard
reset this let's throw out the leftovers
and start over yeah and so I wonder how
many hard resets before you get someone
that can build a spaceship or build a
computer or something you know yeah
didn't take that many only like two for
us to come pop out of there too there
was like a several mass extinctions
right right there were like five so five
resets it took yeah huh I'm sorry I'm
not more of an expert that's I feel like
I'm letting you down you're not letting
me down just think I think I was an
expert while I was making that history
the Rovio there's new stuff in your head
now yeah yeah I think Elon Musk's
believes were living in
in a simulation of what he thinks that
we are living in a computer simulation
of something else entirely that reality
is just a computer simulation of I guess
I guess again that would mean that
someone else's guess someone else is
controlling it for some reason like if
you think of like that okay whatever
yeah all right well I'm excited for your
live show your concert that's there
isn't there isn't I'm excited about the
idea for the idea even that you're
entertaining the ideas I really want to
do it yeah the problem is that I can't
make videos at the same time so I don't
know how much no well if you guys want
to help out bill words if you want to
help support him and his work please
head on over to patreon comm slash bill
words link is in the description I'll
ask because you won't thank you thank
you to you and everybody support bill he
is a gem and I thank you so much for
joining us
oh geez thank you for having me it was
an honor and a privilege and a pleasure
likewise so guys I hope you had a laugh
I hope you had a giggle up we were
fascinated as I was who do we have next
week uh it's not a hundred hundred
percent confirmed but it's a big one if
it does work out I don't know should we
should we sell I think I think it is I
think it's pretty much planned I think
it's happening Jack Black Jack Black
pretty exciting big fans really easy and
cayenne is cut and Kyle's coming on as
well as to just Jack I think it's just
Jack I don't think Kyle's available I
know maybe at an unusual time right yeah
well we'll make a Twitter post maybe an
early one
yeah right in the morning it sounded
like that's the only time I work out but
yeah that looks like it's happening cool
so we'll see you I will see you I think
an unusual time next week but we'll keep
you guys posted on the Twitter account
and once again is there anything else
you want to talk about probably a
million things but I can't remember
bill works on YouTube bill works
everywhere but we accept not bill works
on social media because you can't get
bill works well on Instagram it's not on
and I'm not the words yeah that's a
great all right guys we'll have a
blessed weekend um enjoy enjoy being
alive and when you wake up tomorrow
morning thank God Oh
smiles all smiles baby life alright guys
thank you so much for watching have a
blessed weekend see you next week thank
you
[Music]
[Music]